bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver en
direct sur figaro live christian jacob
patron du parti des républicains est
attendue d'une minute à l'autre pour
faire l'annoncé des résultats du premier
tour du congrès les républicains qui
doit désigner ce samedi le candidat de
la droite à la présidentielle
alors qui de michel barnier et xavier
bertrand eric ciotti philippe juvin ou
valérie pécresse sera au second tour
l'annoncé des résultats était prévue à
14h30 il est déjà 14h32 on attend
l'arrivée de christian jacob un peu
moins de 140 mille adhérents avaient
jusqu'à 14h aujourd'hui pour voter par
voie électronique dans le cadre de ce
premier tour pour commenter ses
résultats à venir à mes côtés carl meeus
bonjour carl un rédacteur en chef au
figaro magazine merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur figaro live je le disais
christian jacob à s'exprimer dans
quelques minutes depuis le siège des
républicains rue drôlerie rue de
vaugirard dans le xvème où se trouvent
les candidats à l'heure à laquelle on se
parle car mu
je pense qu'ils sont pour la plupart
dans leur qg d'accord il veut attendre
alors normalement il devrait pouvoir
avoir les résultats un peu avant nous
que st jakob d'apprendre la pelle il
rappelait vidian pouvoir les appeler
quand même individuellement et ensuite
faire sa conférence de presse donc eux
on peut imaginer qu'ils savent et que
nous on attend on attend donc vous voyez
le pupitre est pour l'instant désert il
est déjà préparée en revanche pour
l'intervention de christian jacob qui ne
devrait plus tarder maintenant je le
disais je parlais d'un peu moins que 140
mille adhérents et l'eire qui était
invité donc à voter jusqu'à 14 heures
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on connaît le taux
de participation à ce scrutin mais alors
il y a deux heures le taux de
participation était à peu près à 78 % ce
qui est un bon taux de participation il
ya certains départements notamment en
ile-de-france où ça se dépasser les 80%
donc c'est plutôt
compte tenu de l'enjeu oui une très très
bonne participation mais dans la mesure
où ce sont que des adhérents au parti on
pourrait s'étonner qu'il ya une petite
marge encore des 20% qui n'a pas
participé au vote c'est vrai qu'on peut
se dire à partir du moment où quelqu'un
a des repères 30 euros notamment pour
voter pourquoi est ce qu'ils ne votent
pas bon il ya deux raisons 1 c'est que
l'on peut estimer peut-être que parfois
il ya des problèmes techniques il y en a
qui n'ont pas pu voter bon voilà ça n'a
pas pu être réglé donc epsilon sajoo la
marge après dans ce corps électoral de
139000 on sait qu'il ya deux catégories
il ya ceux qui étaient adhérents avant
l'organisation du congrès on va dire
jusque fin août là il était à peu près
79000 dans ses 79 miliana peut-être qui
en fait avait adhéré depuis six mois lui
moi un an mais qui n'en fait et est
parti puis non par renault n'ont pas
fait la joie de les intéresser voilà on
l'a engage sont désintéressés en
revanche on est à peu près quand même
sûr que les 70 milles qui ont adhéré
dans cette courte période eux
normalement observé à 100% alors le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que c'est
l'incertitude qui domine personne n'a
les résultats pour l'instant à part les
principaux concernés on l'imaginé en
tout cas au sein des rédactions des
médias comme vous on a pas d'infos pour
l'instant des résultats on peut même pas
à voir des bribes de ce que pourrait
donner ses résultats de premier tour en
tout cas je le disais l'incertitude
domine même depuis le premier débat dlr
on a du mal à déterminer véritablement
celui qui les deux qui sortiront
vainqueurs du premier tour ça veut dire
que le résultat risque d'être très serré
alors pour le coup on n'en sait rien
comme vous dites il n'y a pas eu de
sondages il ya les seuls éléments qu'on
avait c'était éventuellement de se
déplacer dans les fédérations de suivre
les candidats mais même là c'était
compliqué de savoir parce que chaque
candidat pouvait le dire j'ai retourné
la salle oui j'ai réussi en commun qu'il
ya des gens qui ont adhéré pour moi on
sait qu'il ya des régions où le le
nombre d'adhérents a littéralement
explosé par exemple la fédération de
paris re devenue la première fédération
au sein des verts on se dit comme ça
spontanément oui ben alors fédération de
paris la présidente de la région ile de
france c'est valérie pécresse ça peut
l'ubs est difficile mais après tout
michel barnier avait aussi des soutiens
à paris donc c'est très compliqué à la
fois de savoir qui a pu bénéficier de
l'augmentation du nombre d'adhérents et
ensuite dans le score je serais tenté de
dire je serai peut-être démenti dans la
seconde qui vient oui c'est pas grave
mais quand on regarde le la primaire des
écologistes
c'était très serré
ils étaient tous sortis à peu près avec
un score assez identiques à quelques
centaines de voix près c'est possible
qu'on soit dans cette configuration là
ce qui ne change rien il y aura toujours
que deux qualifiés pour le second tour
qui aura lieu samedi mais il n'y a pas
une tendance qu'on a pu détecter décelé
chez les adhérents il n'ya pas des
sondages qui ont été fait auprès des
adhérents pour savoir un peu sur quel
pendant son partenaire vous pouvez pas
faire de sondages tous les instituts
vous dise 1 le corps électoral est trop
faible 2 il est émouvant il a quand même
fallu attendre le 16 novembre pour ce
corps électoral soit figé donc tous les
sondages que vous faisiez avant vous
pouviez les mettre à la poubelle
regardez en septembre vous avez un corps
électoral à soixante dix neuf mille
adhérents le 26 novembre il est à 150
milles et en réalité ensuite il est
redescendu à 139,8 parce que il ya des
gens qui n'avaient pas laissé leur
numéro de portable or comme c'est un
vote électronique fallait laisser soit
un numéro de portable soit un numéro de
mails pour pouvoir récupérer des codes
qui permettent de voter donc c'était
impossible et vous pouviez
éventuellement tester les adhérents par
exempe après les débats c'est vrai
qu'après les débats on a eu des
impressions mais est ce que l'impression
que moi j'ai pu avoir ou que vous avez
pu avoir est ce qu'elle est partagée par
l'ensemble des sites en main le militant
est quelqu'un de quand même d'assez
particulier quelqu'un qui qui payent
pour adhérer à un parti politique qui
s'engagent dans ce parti politique il a
des idées très précises on peut penser
que les 70 milles qui ont qui sont venus
pour voter savez pour qu'ils allaient
voter donc que les débats finalement non
pas forcément changer leurs modes
exactement on a dit au début à michel
barnier au et bichonnent barnier est
favori parce qu'il avait plus de d'élus
qui le soutenaient mais aujourd'hui on
sait que c'est pas parce que le
président de la fédération soutient x
que l'ensemble des militants de cette
fédération sont derrière x ou y
aujourd'hui les gens votent librement et
même à linverse on aurait plutôt
tendance à dire c'est pas parce que un
homme politique vous dit je vais faire
ça je vous engage à faire ça que les
gens vont suivre c'est bien d'être
plutôt l inverse les gens veulent garder
leur libre arbitre si vous nous
rejoignez en ce moment en direct sur
figaro l'arrivée sur notre chaîne
youtube nous sommes en train d'attendre
l'arrivée de christian jacob le voyait
sur ces images derrière son pupitre il
devrait se se positionner dans quelques
minutes pour annoncer donc le résultat
du premier tour du congrès dlr un
résultat très attendu beaucoup de
suspense il est très difficile de
définir en l'état quel pourrait être le
duo gagnant de ce premier tour un duo
qui s'affrontera jusqu'à samedi ensuite
pour avoir le candidat définitif qui
fera campagne pour la présidentielle
vous êtes déjà un certain nombre sur les
réseaux sociaux du figaro et je vous en
remercie je vous salue je sais le kriss
kross éternel fidèles de figaro live
merci jacques cazabat jean paul ii aussi
fidèle au tchad figaro live nathan 770
certains d'entre vous nous parle de des
tendances qui se dessinent sur les
réseaux sociaux mais encore une fois ils
n'ont qu'une valeur puisque à priori
ce ne sont pas tombés donc on ne peut
pas savoir qui est donc je ne citerai
pas les tendances et alors ya un élément
clé sur les réseaux sociaux et un
élément pardon je coupe qui se rajoutent
qui est intéressant c'est marion mourgue
et oui du figaro au service politique
différent qui nous disent sur twitter
les candidats aient l'air n'ont aucun
retour leurs représentants ont dû poser
leur téléphone pour connaître les
résultats donc peut-être qu'ils nous
regardent peut-être qu'il ils sont
devant les chaînes info voilà même les
candidats même les candidats les
principes moment concerné ne sommes pas
informés des résultats apparemment du
moteur c'est absolument incroyable on
est on a rarement été dans une situation
comme comme celle ci vous vous évoquez
en off avant qu'on débute cette émission
le cas des présidentielles où depuis
maintenant des dizaines d'années on a
l'habitude et les rédactions l'habitude
en amont d'avoir déjà les tendances pour
pouvoir oui parce que parce que dans une
présidentielle en fait vous avez les
sondeurs qui fondent et des questions à
la sortie des urnes mais il faut malgré
tout il faut se méfier des sondages
sortie des urnes on a vu on a appris en
2002 lors de la présidentielle de 2002
que les gens me mentais à la sortie des
stands mais après vous avez des bureaux
de vote qui ferment plus tôt des bureaux
tests et donc ils savent dès les
premiers 100 des cent premiers
dépouillements on a des tendances et
donc ils peuvent extrapoler et la avoir
des sondages assez assez fiable je
prends la primaire de 2016 qui était une
première beaucoup plus large les 4
millions participe à 100 participants là
on avait une tendance parce que pour le
coup il y avait eu des sondages et qui
avait montré que dans les dix derniers
jours il y avait une progression
incroyable de de françois fillon mais
même là le au moment du résultat on
n'imaginait pas que françois fillon est
allé gagner même ses propres lieutenants
la semaine avant le vote nous disait une
journaliste politique pour eelv a
terminé à 30% c'est bien on sera déjà
content on n'y sera pas humilier quatre
jours après il l'emportait il emportait
avec une vague tellement énorme que
presque certains se demandaient s'il
était utile de faire un second tour
tellement on savait que son avance était
importante donc là voilà vous avez
entièrement raison c'est inédit
on découvrira ça nous les journalistes
en même temps que tout le monde et je
pense que ça doit plaire à tout le monde
voilà donc il est 14h41 car oui vous
avez raison on attend ce résultat est
dans une configuration inédite ou où
personne n'était au courant de du duo
qui devrait être annoncé par christian
jacob patron d'ea l'air dans quelques
minutes vous êtes je le disais nombreux
à faire des commentaires sur les réseaux
sociaux du figaro en particulier sur
youtube où je vois de commentaires dont
un
qui vous est adressée carl meeus je vais
le site et après dans un premier temps
certains d'entre vous sont assez acide
je vois et ligue août farde qui nous dit
tout ça pour perdre dans six mois
qu'est-ce qu'on lui répond et liban lui
réponds qu'on en sait rien que je vous
parle dont je lis mais voilà apparemment
on s'orienterait vers un ciotti pécresse
on attend quand même que ça soit
conforme conf confirmé firme il va c'est
ça serait une tendance je sais pas on en
attend de voir mais non vous ne pouvez
pas savoir à cette époque-là en 2016
françois fillon sortait de la primaire
les sondages donnaient à 30 % quasiment
et lui semble sans difficulté on a vu ce
qu'il en était mais la gauche chirac en
95 annonce que voilà comme elie qui nous
dit voilà même quel que soit le
vainqueur du second tour de la primaire
dlr de toute façon en six mois c'est
plié ça sera pas ça sera ni l'un ni
l'autre est-ce qu'on peut présager que
au bout en bout du chemin finalement ça
ne passera pas on peut rien présager un
parlement
l'intérêt d'une campagne électorale
c'est justement que les choses peuvent
changer j'allais vous prendre l'exemple
de jacques chirac en décembre bien 194
il n'est pas qualifié il est dans les
choux au point que on lui dit mais
est-ce que vous avez pas vous retirer
dans ma lettre dur doit être élu sans
problème c'est pas de crise de février
que des choses se décident on va écouter
christian jacob dont on annonce
l'arrivée devant le pupitre si la régie
peut nous montrer les images
voilà
on aimerait avoir un peu prise de sang
s'il vous plaît ben en régie
de rassemblement au moment où la gauche
est totalement divisée au moment où le
rassemblement national éclaté entre deux
blocs et puis au moment où la république
en marche chacun en est à créer sa
propre chapelle donc d'abord tout le
monde est revenu chez les ch et les
républicains et s'y sent bien je pense
pouvoir en témoigner tout le monde a
parfaitement accepté le processus de
désignation
et puis notre calendrier était le bon
puisque c'est notre calendrier qui a
donné le tempo parce que si j'en crois
tout ceci notamment je crois tous les
éditorialistes depuis quelques jours
nous sommes devenus le sujet numéro un
de préoccupations des membres du
gouvernement et des membres du
rassemblement national tout cela est lié
deux choses d'abord à la qualité de nos
candidats qui ont été remarquables les
uns les autres
avec des débats de très haut niveau de
très bonnes de très bonne qualité et
puis aussi à notre projet pour la france
où nous avons redéfini un socle
idéologique auquel de au sein duquel nos
candidats se sont parfaitement retrouvé
alors chacun y a été avec son
tempérament sa sensibilité ses priorités
mais
tout le monde est resté dans ce socle et
puis dernier point de satisfaction et
pas des moindres c'est le taux de
participation
et puis je voudrais ici aussi en
profiter pour remercier féliciter le
président de notre autorité de contrôle
philippe bas
qui avait que ses deux collègues ont
fait un travail d'une rigueur qu'on
connaît au 3 et notamment à philippe
vous aurez vraiment le remercier
sincèrement parce que ils ont donné de
leur temps avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
rigueur dont toute participation
remarquable je rappelle qu'au 16
novembre nous avions 148 1862 militants
à jour de cotisation
139 1742 était en situation de voter en
situation de voter ça veut dire que il
avait à renseigner vous savez qu'on
avait en accord avec philippe bami le
niveau 3 de contrôler le niveau maximum
c'est à dire que ces 139 1742 militants
ont dû renseigner une adresse postale
une adresse mail et un numéro de
portable ils ont reçu sur leur adresse
portable leur adresse postale
l'identifiant sur le mail leur numéro
d'adhérent et sur le numéro de portable
code pour pouvoir voter donc sur ses 130
9742 qui est militants qui étaient en
situation de voter 113000 0,38 ont voté
ce qui nous fait un taux de
participation de
81,80 9% dont excellent taux de
participation
les les résultats maintenant sont les
sont les suivants donc philippe juvin a
recueilli
3532 voix
3,13 %
xavier bertrand a recueilli 25 mille
deux cent treize voix
22,36 %
michel barnier a recueilli 26
1970 voit
23,93 % valérie pécresse
a recueilli 28 mille
179 voix 25% eric ciotti a recueilli 28
1844 voix 25 59 % donc seront à
départager au deuxième tour qui va
s'ouvrir dès demain matin 8 heures eric
ciotti et valérie pécresse voilà pour
les résultats
je vous remercie
[Musique]
bon merci merci de votre attention et
merci de l'écho que vous donnerez à
cette très belle campagne est très belle
participation du premier la qualité du
vote du congrès des républicains pour la
course à la candidature à la
présidentielle donc christian jacob
vient de nous annoncer que c'est eric
ciotti et valérie pécresse qui sont en
lice pour le second tour dont les
résultats devraient parvenir ce samedi
carl meeus comment faut-il analyser ses
résultats ce type et creysse qu'est ce
qu'ont voulu dire les adhérents alors
les adhérents ont voulu signaler un
sacré coup de barre à droite en plaçant
ciotti en tête c'est malgré tout on peut
le dire une très grande surprise il ne
faisait pas partie des favoris au début
de cette campagne plutôt un petit
candidat dont on disait bon il est dans
son couloir il va faire son petit score
et tout ça et au fur et à mesure des
débats en fait il s'est imposé il a
quasiment presque imposé la ligne des
débats ce qu'on a vu que chaque fois les
autres candidats pour la plupart
sans adhérer à ce qu'il disait se
rapprochait de ses positions que ce soit
sur le droit du sol sur l'armée en
banlieue ou des choses comme ça
au fond on pourrait presque comparer
j'espère qu'il ne m'en voudra pas de la
comparaison mais c'est un peu le
sandrine rousseau dlr à la primaire des
écolos sandrine rousseau elle aussi
n'était pas la plus favorite mais sur
une campagne très radicale avec des
positions très radicaliser elle a créé
la surprise en se qualifiant face à
yannick jadot et ensuite et elle n'a pas
été élue c'est là la difficulté pour
eric ciotti c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils
voient bien qu'ils se qualifient pour le
second tour mais la victoire va être
difficile parce que on n'imagine pas
mais je vais pas anticiper sur vos
autres questions du coup la présence de
valérie pécresse dans ce duo final
est ce que c'est un pour elle la
garantie de l'emporter samedi on peut le
dire après il faut attendre ce que les
adhérents mais on imagine mal
xavier bertrand ou michel barnier ne pas
appeler à voter pour valérie pécresse et
même philippe juin donc ça lui fait un
potentiel de voix de quelques 75 % ça
sera évidemment pas ça au final parce
que je pense qu'il ya des adhérents qui
était sincèrement pour michel barnier ou
pour xavier bertrand qui se
désintéresseront peut-être du second
tour donc là partira ce n'est pas la
même à propos de xavier bertrand sa
place d'avant dernier aujourd'hui c'est
une surprise aussi malgré le fait qu'on
était dans le flou et le brouillard
jusqu'à la l'annoncé des résultats tout
à fait c'est une alors j'ai à dire c'est
une demi surprise
pour les observateurs on avait depuis le
début compris qu'il avait choisi la
stratégie la plus risquée d'ailleurs il
le disait lui-même du jour où il décide
d'aller devant les adhérents et l'air il
sait qu'il prend le plus grand risque de
sa vie politique si le vote avait eu
lieu en septembre il disait je sais que
j'ai perdu pour quelle raison parce que
lui c'est celui qui est un de ceux qui a
quitté les l air mais avec pertes et
fracas dès 2017 et qui ensuite de suis
allé lui de la campagne les ont bien
voilà je pense ça ça lui a pas été
pardonnés et puis toute cette campagne
au début à partir ont ils se déclare
candidat jusqu'en septembre en disant
non mais la présidentielle c'est la
rencontre entre un homme et un peuple je
n'irai pas devant les élèves je ne
participerai paris donc il a braqué
beaucoup de militants et pendant toute
la campagne il a essayé de leur
expliquer en disant voilà je fait le
chemin inverse maintenant je viens vers
vous mais ça n'a pas suffi on va
rappeler les résultats précisément 25 59
% des votes pour eric ciotti 25% pour
valérie pécresse 23 93 % pour michel
barnier
22,36 % pour xavier bertrand et 3% pour
philippe juvin vous parliez tout à
l'heure d
des votes des ceux qui n'ont pas été
retenus par les adhérents et qui serait
tourné possiblement vers valérie
pécresse que va-t-il se passer
maintenant donc ça veut dire que des
consignes officielles vont être données
alors certes à sion où on va avoir lieu
il n'y a pas beaucoup de temps oui le
second tour démarre demain à 8 heures du
matin pour s'achever samedi à 14 heures
donc il ya un laps de temps qui est
assez court pendant lequel oui il peut y
avoir des tractations elles vont être
assez rapide malgré tout comme je vous
le disais on imagine mal quand même
michel barnier appelé à se ranger
derrière eric ciotti ou xavier bertrand
appelé à se ranger derrière valérie
pécresse donc là il va y avoir sûrement
valérie pécresse qui va prendre la
parole pour féliciter ceux qui l'ont
soutenu et se projeter dans le second
tour sachant que elle n'a que jusqu'à ce
soir je crois que c'est minuit pour pour
s'exprimer publiquement et ensuite elle
devra faire
respecter une sorte de silence radio
eric ciotti lui bah il va fêter sa
victoire il va peut-être essayer de
récupérer
des voix parmi ceux qui se sont porté
chez les autres on voit assez peu
d'abstentionnistes 80 89 % de
participation c'est malgré tout très
élevé
mais il a déjà réussi son pari eric
ciotti montre qu'il va falloir compter
avec lui je reprends encore une fois
parce que c'est le dernier exemple en
date et puis c'est le plus frappant on
voit que chez les écologistes sandrine
rousseau est présente dans la campagne
de nier yannick jadot s'allumant pèse
dans cette campagne peut-être pèse à la
façon d'un boulet pour yannick jadot ça
on verra après mais en tout cas fait
valoir c'est ses électeurs de la
primaire eric ciotti fera la même chose
alors chardon bleu sur sur le tchad
figaro live nous précise effectivement à
propos de valérie pécresse elle aussi
elle avait quitté les nerfs et améliorer
les adhérents ne lui en tiennent pas
rigueur comment l'expliquer alors pour à
mon avis deux raisons la première raison
c'est qu'elle s'était un peu rapprochées
dlr largement avant xavier bertrand vous
souvenez
l'université des jeunes l'été de non pas
celle ci mais celle d'avant à port-marly
elle était venue parler devant le campus
des jeunes donc déjà là il y avait eu un
rapprochement avant les élections
régionales ensuite pendant les relations
générales mais accepte évidemment le
soutien des élèves et surtout au moment
où il était question devait avoir
réalisé une primaire où un vote interne
elle a tout de suite accepté de jouer le
jeu là où xavier bertrand était plutôt
dans l'idée mais non moi je ne joue pas
le jeu jeux conçus je poursuis mon petit
bonhomme de chemin et ensuite une fois
que lui a accepté de jouer le jeu et
elle est rentrée dans le giron aussi des
alertes elle a tout de suite dit je
prends ma carte évidemment je ne peux
pas demander aux gens d'adhérer à l'air
de voter pour moi si moi même je ne
reprends pas ma carte et on se souvient
xavier bertrand y ait eu une valse
hésitation il a dit devant les sénateurs
mais non il est hors de question que je
reprenne ma carte et puis deux jours
après se rendant compte que c'était
malgré tout une erreur politique a
repris sa carte donc je pense
qu'effectivement la l'acrimonie d
adhérence et plus tourné vers xavier
bertrand que vers valérie pécresse le
deuxième élément qui joue aussi on
n'aura pas les chiffres par rare
fédération et par département c'est un
peu dommage mais bon voilà c'est
peut-être trop compliqué on verra si on
peut les obtenir la fin mais on sait que
au niveau des adhésions lille 2 france
c'est excessivement renforcée je vous le
disais tout à l'heure fin août
l'ile-de-france peser 20 % à peu près du
corps électoral à la fin le 11 novembre
très présent elle peser 25% donc elle a
augmenté le poids et la en ile de france
visiblement il ya eu une prime à valérie
pécresse ça a plus profité aussi un peu
à michel barnier puisqu'ils passent
devant xavier bertrand mais ça a été
porté au crédit de librairies pécresse
les hôtes france il ya eu une
augmentation aussi du poids des hauts de
france au sein de l'appareil au sein des
adhérents mais ils sont passés de 5 5% à
6% voyez bien ce n'était pas suffisant
la présence d'une femme en l'occurrence
dans ce débat la présence d'une femme
dans cette compétition est ce que ça a
pu être aussi un atout pour valérie
pécresse indépendamment de ces
compétences qui sont soulignés avec
cette adhésion à sa candidature et ses
actions sur la région ile de france vous
disiez le fait d'être une femme aussi ça
a pu jouer
peut-être je serais tenter de vous dire
je n'espère pas j'espère que les gens
votent plutôt pour les idées et leye et
la compétence que pour le pour le genre
après cela dit c'était la seule femme
voilà si quelqu'un voulait faire ce
choix là en fonction de ce critère là il
n'avait qu'un choix possible
elle n'en a pas forcément usées elle
n'était pas à dire tout le temps comme
l'avait fait ségolène royal en son temps
vous m'attaquez parce que je suis une
femme je suis là pour représenter les
femmes aurel elle était beaucoup dans
voilà moi ce que je vais faire je vous
promet des choses que je saurai faire
parce que je l' ai déjà fait à la à la
région donc ça c'est peut-être ça qui a
joué après il faut pas oublier quelque
chose si c'est que valérie pécresse a
choisi comme directeur de campagne
patrick stefanini qui est quelqu'un qui
sait faire campagne qui s'est mobilisé
des troupes qui a mobiliser les gens
pour les faire adhérer qui a fait des
tracts qui a ils ont fait beaucoup de
phoning aussi pour faire adhérer les
gens et donc c'est quelqu'un de très
efficace et on le voit le résultat
aujourd'hui je vais
voilà vous signifier le une réflexion de
charles martel charles martel pardon sur
le chat figaro live qui nous dit valérie
pécresse comme chef de la région ile de
france a montré ses compétences
on n'a pas parlé d'irriguer moore dans
quelle mesure la candidature d'eric
zemmour qui vise à mordre sur
l'électorat de la droite influe-t-elle
le choix des votants aujourd'hui on voit
que la présence d'eric ciotti en tête de
cette compétition n'est pas anodine est
ce qu'elle est marquée aussi par le fait
qu'en face il ya un compétiteur je moi
j'ai un ver serait en fait si vous aussi
vous voulez bien la proposition je pense
que la présence d'eric ciotti a
peut-être empêché le départ où
l'abstention d'un certain nombre de
d'adhérents vers eric zemmour eric
ciotti est le seul qui a dit que lui
dans un duel macron zemmour il voter et
règlements il est le seul à avoir pris
des positions assez clair pour dire eric
zemmour est un ami bon et donc au fond
il solidifie des gens qui peut être
auraient pu être tentés d'aller voir
chez eric zemmour en se disant c'est pas
valérie pécresse s'est pas michel
barnier s'est pas xavier bertrand qui
qui qui sauront ils répondre ça c'est le
premier élément deuxième élément on l'a
vu dans la campagne il a entraîné les
autres candidats vers ces positions l'a
donc de ce fait on voit que les deux
candidats qui ont des positions assez
forte sur les sujets de l'immigration et
de la sécurité valérie pécresse veut
réformer la constitution pour changer
les entrées dans l'immigration sur la
sécurité à la mission très forte en
disant il faut que les peines ne soient
pas les mêmes selon l'endroit où elles
sont commises c'est à dire que si vous
le faites dans paris intra muros ou dans
une banlieue déjà difficile vous n'aurez
pas la même peine c'est des choses qui
font hurler certains magistrats mais qui
voit là parlent peut-être aussi à lectra
donc c'est intéressant de voir que l a
pris ses positions là et elle arrive en
deuxième position avec eric ciotti en
première position si vous nous rejoignez
à l'instant sur figaro live et sur notre
chaîne youtube et bien on vient d'avoir
une annonce en direct de christian jacob
le patron des républicains qui vient
donc d'annoncer que au second tour de
cette primaire de ce congrès des
républicains qui vise à avoir un
candidat pour la présidentielle c'est
eric ciotti qui est en tête avec valérie
pécresse donc c'est le duo qui est en
lice pour le second tour dont les
résultats seront donnés en direct sur le
figaro ce samedi à 14h30 en votre
présence car mes yeux c'est en présence
de bruno dray qui sera aux manettes et
présentation ce samedi merci beaucoup
karl merci pour ces analyses et
commentaires sur ses résultats
j'ai précisé simplement qu'en troisième
position c'est michel barnier qui est
arrivé avec 23 points 93 % suivi par
xavier bertrand 22 36 % et enfin
philippe juvin arrive oui vous
interrompez non jeu à tort parce qu'en
bon on est peut-être passé rapidement
mais xavier bertrand a dit que s'ils
perdaient oui il arrêtait la vie
politique et que donc apparemment cet
argument n'a pas suffi pour convaincre
les adhérents mais que pour lui c'est
voilà c'est quand même très violent oui
on savait que ça serait violent pour un
peut-être deux des favoris le résultat
d'aujourd'hui c'est xavier bertrand qui
prend en pleine figure ce qui j'ose dire
la porte des républicains parce que par
rapport à déclaration de candidature
vous souvenez des 20 heures oui les jeux
je battrai emmanuel macron il ne réunit
que
25200 suffrages est donc pour lui
aujourd'hui d'après ce puisqu'il nous
l'a dit sa vie politique s'arrête sa vie
politique s'arrête ça veut dire qu'elle
s'arrête maintenant ou est ce qu'il va
être au bout du chemin qui mène à la
présidentielle pour sa consoeur si on
peut dire ça comme ça valérie pécresse
alors il ne l'a pas précisé de la même
façon qu'il n'a pas précisé s'il
démissionnait de la présidence de la
région hôte france qu'il ira au bout
d'eux quand même malgré tout son mandat
autour de lui il ya des gens qui peuvent
le convaincre de 2 justement de ne pas
baisser les bras que c'est peut-être un
il ya une défaite mais
après les défaites on peut apprendre de
ces défaites et enchaînés vers d'autres
victoires si mitterrand chirac d'autres
arrêtées après des défaites voilà
l'histoire aurait été différente la
portée est violemment claqué quand même
c'est très violent
effectivement je pense qu'il s'y
attendait il savait qu'il n'avait pas
choisi la la la route la plus facile
malgré tout il faut faut digérer il va
falloir du temps merci encore call me
dit sport et
vous et vos analyses merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis en direct et d'avoir
fait nous fait pas de nous avoir fait
part de vos commentaires sur le chat de
figaro live et sur celui de youtube à
très vite sur figaro live